Boris Johnson has been found to have
misled the country this unelected Prime
Minister should now resign
[Applause]
I got that bit that would make him the
shortest serving British prime minister
in history and rightly so we will bring
people together a Labour government will
transform our economies and our
communities we stand not just for the 52
percent or the 48 percent but we stand
for the 99 percent
[Applause]
that's why if the bridge people elect a
Labour government in the coming election
I'll be very proud to be your Prime
Minister because I will be I promise you
this a very different kind of Prime
Minister
not
not there from a sense of born to rule
entitlement certainly absolutely promise
you this certainly not there on a
personal power trip Shadow Cabinet would
confirm that that's because I want to
put government on your side
what power and wealth into your hands
there because I believe government
should work for you and together we can
go beyond defending the gains made by
previous generations we stand on the
shoulders that went as those that went
before us but we have to take it further
and it's time we started to build a
country fit for the next generation